aktuell werden rund 30.000 der
theoretisch möglichen 100.000
Postleitzahlen in Deutschland benutzt
aber was passiert wenn man einfach
random eine Postleitzahl generiert und
genau dort 24 Stunden lang verbringt
genau das habe ich gemacht und fünf
Freunde von mir angerufen die mir eine
Zahl von 1 bis 10 nennen sollten am Ende
ist dann eine Postleitzahl entstanden
und dort bin ich hingesüßt und es hat
sich auf jeden Fall gelohnt viel Spaß
mit einem neuen Reisevideo und damit jo
Leute was geht ab herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen Video ihr habt sicherlich
gerade schon gehört was heute passiert
und zwar werden wir eine random
Postleitzahl generieren lassen da werde
ich dann hinfahren ich habe leider
niemanden gefunden der mitkommen ich
hatte mir sehr gewünscht dass irgendwie
einen Freund mitkommen weil alleine ist
es halt manchmal ein bisschen doof aber
ich versuche natürlich trotzdem das
Beste daraus zu machen und eigentlich 30
auch was immer alleine für meine Youtube
Videos nur ich mache halt noch eine
Deutschland Edition und deswegen ist es
auch nicht so weit weil da müssen alle
meine Freunde arbeiten wir haben jetzt
mitten in der Woche am Wochenende kann
ich nicht und ich dachte mir hey komm du
ziehst das jetzt diese Woche dann halt
einfach alleine durch ich weiß ich habe
vor ungefähr einem Jahr schon mal so ein
Video gemacht hier könnt ihr das sehen
da sind wir okay ich will nicht für die
ist noch nicht gesehen haben checkt
einfach aus aber wir machen das heute
einmal mit der Deutschland Edition und
dann machen wir es mit der
europa-edition im nächsten Video also
dass ich wirklich eine Postleitzahl mir
generieren lasse die irgendwo in Europa
sein kann und heute geht es halt nur um
irgendeine random Stadt in Deutschland
wahrscheinlich landen wir wieder im
letzten Kuhdorf irgendwo aber wir werden
mal sehen kurz noch zu Erklärung falls
es keine Stadt gibt die diesen fünf
Ziffern entspricht weil es gibt halt nur
30.000 Postleitzahlen in Deutschland und
fünfstellige Möglichkeiten werden ja bis
100.000 dann nehme ich die letzte Ziffer
wieder weg und dann entspricht die
vierstellige Zahl aber irgendeiner
Postleitzahl die mir dann sofort oben
angezeigt wird und die nehmen wir dann
kann man glaube ich verstehen oder wir
haben gar nicht lange und ich rufe mal
als erstes mein Bruder an und danach
natürlich auch irgendwelche influencers
hallo hi na was geht du ähm Arbeit
[Musik]
ich mache jetzt heute eine kleine
Roadtrip und du musst mir jetzt einmal
eine Zahl zwischen 1 und 9 sagen also 1
bis 9 Uhr irgendeine Zahl dazwischen
oder eins oder neun kannst ja einer
aussuchen
okay das war's schon als nächstes rufe
ich meine Freundin an dir glaube ich
schon lange nicht mehr gehört habe also
erste Zimmer weiß auf jeden Fall schon
mal neun hi Na
du musst mir mal ganz schnell eine Zahl
nennen zwischen 1 und 9 ist egal also
kann irgendwas dazwischen sein kann auch
eins sein kann auch sein
als eins
alles klar das war's schon jetzt suche
ich mir irgendeinen Youtuber raus Heiko
Lochmann mal gucken ob der rangeht was
geht na ja muss bei dir
ach so ja ich will dich gar nicht lange
aufhalten ich habe nur eine ganz kurze
eine ganz kurze Aufgabe für dich sag mir
mal eine Zahl zwischen 1 und 9
ähm weil ich mir gerade so eine
Postleitzahl generieren lasse und dann
fliege ich dahin oder fahre dahin
ja kannst ja mitkommen ich suche immer
wenn der mitkommen
AR wow
ja okay ich weiß im Hintergrund
ja jetzt gleich
oh ja
[Applaus]
okay danke
ja ja okay ein brauche ich noch gucken
ob der dran geht das hatte ich auch
lange nicht dass alle direkt dran gehen
als ich dachte das wird jetzt wieder ein
Krampf willkommen bei o2 soviel dazu wir
haben jetzt halt auch schon 15 Uhr also
kommt halt drauf an wie weit es ist aber
ich muss noch mal so langsam loskommen
geh einfach mal meine ganze Telefonliste
durch
[Musik]
und jetzt los
ist und deshalb habe ich mir gedacht
[Musik]
also manche Leute haben vielleicht noch
irgendein Mädel Lotti kennt ihr die wenn
ich auch hier ist immer ein Foto
eingebildet auch total nett die
Rufnummer an vielleicht können wir ja
noch eine Ziffern hi
Alex wie geht's
auch soweit du pass auf ich will gar
nicht lange stören ich habe nur eine
Aufgabe für dich du musst immer einmal
eine Zahlen zwischen 1 und 9
drei drei okay das war es sogar schon
alles klar dann danke dir und bis dann
Ciao 9 1 5
4 3 ah Mississippi ja okay das war das
was ich meinte weil es halt dazu keine
Postleitzahl in Deutschland gibt
deswegen würde ich jetzt einfach eine
Ziffer wegnehmen und dann haben wir als
erstes pro 91541 Rothenburg ob der
Tauber bitte nicht 340 km wo ist denn
das viereinhalb Stunden boah krass ist
sieht voll schön aus habe ich aber noch
nie gehört viereinhalb Stunden das heißt
ich bin um 19:30 Uhr da wenn ich jetzt
losfahre ich muss noch meine Sachen
packen na ja dann geht's heute nach
Rotenburg ob der Tauber dann machen wir
uns mal auf dem Weg Rotenburg ob der
Tauber das ist eine große Stadt nee nee
das kann ja nicht so groß dann gibt's da
ein Hotel das ermittle ich noch bis
gleich im Auto wurde gestartet okay also
ich habe das jetzt mal eingegeben
394 km Ankunft 18:2 20 wobei dieses BMW
Navi denkt wirklich immer ich bin
Michael Schumacher Alter das wird auf
jeden Fall ein Ritter ich würde sagen
nicht lang schnacken keine Zeit
verlieren auf auf die Autobahn ab nach
auf der Tauber dicker also es läuft noch
nicht gut erstmal haben wir hinter mir
gerade einen LKW der sein Reifen seht
ihr das glaub dein Reifen ist geplatzt
und es ist nur am regnen so eine Scheiße
boah ey der muss mal anhalten checkt dir
das gar nicht Alter ist das ein Qualm
ich glaube der Reiz gar nicht naja 130
km habe ich schon hinter mir 2076 km
sind doch 18:55 Uhr bin ich da laut Navi
ob das klappt schauen mich so auf ne
gefühlt alles hier sind Baustellen ich
muss so hart pissen jetzt ist selbst der
Rasthof hier eine Baustelle und alles
steht im Stau ja toll also bis jetzt
läuft heute wirklich noch gar nichts
okay Leute ich bin jetzt mittlerweile
bei einem anderen Rastplatz und bevor
wir jetzt schauen in welches Hotel ich
da gehe ich habe schon geguckt da gibt's
einige Hotels ihr wisst Leute ich bin
andauernd unterwegs und die Videos vor
allem die Reisevideos sind immer Arsch
teuer deswegen versuche ich da
logischerweise immer einen guten
Überblick zu behalten und das geht am
besten mit finanzguru und warum das so
toll ist und ihr eure Finanzen damit
ganz einfach im Überblick haben könnt
das erkläre ich euch mal finanzguru ist
eine App die wie der Name schon sagt
natürlich was mit Finanzen zu tun hat
und der große Vorteil ist ihr könnt mit
der App alle eure Finanzen sei es von
der Kreditkarte eurem Girokonto euren
Aktiendepots euren PayPal Konto und
sogar eure bündeln und habe immer ein
perfekten Überblick wie viel Geld ihr
für was bezahlt habt sprich ihr könnt
erkennen wie viel habe ich für
Lebensmittel ausgegeben wie viel für
Shopping wie viel für tanken und so
weiter und so fort außerdem könnt ihr
alle eure abgeschlossenen Abos einsehen
und die sogar über die finanzguru App
ganz einfach kündigen weil vieles
braucht man vielleicht auch gar nicht
mehr aber hat sich mehr wirklich im Kopf
dass man das eigentlich noch hat ich
habe zum Beispiel drei verschiedene
Konten und drei verschiedene
Kreditkarten und da den Überblick zu
bewahren ist schon gar nicht mal so
einfach und durch finanzguru weiß jetzt
auch wo ich nächsten Monat vielleicht
ein bisschen noch sparen könnte das
Beste ist finanzguru ist durchgehend
kostenlos ihr könnt eine plus Variante
abschließen da habe ich auch einen Code
für euch dann habt ihr jetzt erstmal
drei Monate umsonst die ist auch auf
jeden Fall ganz geil aber so die
grundsätzlichen Features sind halt
kostenlos wenn ihr euch finanzguru
downloadet über meinen Link in der
Videobeschreibung und dort den Code Alex
eingibt innerhalb der nächsten 30 Tage
dann bekommt ihr anstatt 7 Tage
finanzguru Plus für gleich 3 Monate oben
drauf und könnt alles verwenden ihr
bekommt geile Analysen Sparpläne und so
weiter Vorschläge wo kann man sparen wie
schafft man sein Privatvermögen zu
erhöhen indem man halt nicht so viel
ausgibt für unnötige Sachen also
grundsätzlich wirklich eine mega geile
App und wenn man nur leichtes Gefühl hat
ich habe nicht so ganz in Überblick bei
meinen Finanzen dann holt euch
finanzguru und wir machen jetzt weiter
mit dem Video okay also von heute 15
August auf 16 August ja da sind echt
viele Hotels ne guck mal ich weiß nicht
wie das genau im Stadtzentrum ist mit
Parken weil diese Hotels sind jetzt alle
genau im Stadtzentrum ob man da easy
parken kann dieses hier zum Beispiel
Villa Mittermeier
so heißt das so ein Comedian das finde
ich sieht eigentlich ganz gut aus und
ist auch nicht direkt im Stadtzentrum da
kann ich bestimmt auch parken beste
Bewertung komm scheiß drauf das nehmen
war 143 €. okay super Buchung ist
bestätigt dann fahren wir jetzt mal
schnell dahin dafür nämlich dass ich vor
20 Jahren komme das wäre sonst echt ein
bisschen spät okay Leute wir haben jetzt
mittlerweile halb acht ich muss erstmal
sagen keine Sorge ich habe hier die
Kontrolle die Kamera halt nur eine Hand
anguck weiterhin geradeaus auf jeden
Fall ist die Landschaft hier wirklich
sehr sehr schön und da vorne geht jetzt
auch gerade die Sonne unter das ist
jetzt das erste Mal dass die Sonne
scheint wäre meiner Reise und vielleicht
könnt ihr jetzt im head up Display sehen
ich bin in 1,9 km da ist die Abfahrt
Richtung Rotenburg schön
also ich bin echt mal gespannt was da
denn jetzt auf mich zukommt was geht
heute noch da steht Rotenburg odt outfit
of the day nee was geht denn heute Abend
noch in Rotenburg ich habe auch noch
nicht geguckt was das so eigentlich für
eine Stadt ist nichts gegoogelt das
machen wir gleich zusammen erst wenn ich
im Hotel bin finde ich es dann ein
bisschen spannender und jetzt fahren wir
hier runter vielleicht ist es schon das
da wahrscheinlich oder das hier ist
jetzt die Ausfahrt okay hier muss ich
jetzt rechts ach so zwei Kilometer noch
da könnte ich lesen 2 km noch grün bis
gleich wir sind jetzt schon in Rotenburg
es gibt doch bestimmt auch Zuschauer von
mir die hier wohnen guck mal wie lustig
oder stellt euch mal vor ihr seht das
jetzt und denkt euch so ja da wohne ich
vielleicht sie sogar kennst du mich oh
schaut mal hier gibt's so ganz Subway
und eigentlich gibt es einen kleinen
Städten kein Subway das heißt hier
müsste schon etwas größer sein Okay
Leute angekommen also im Hintergrund ist
auf jeden Fall mein Hotel auf dem Land
kann man immer umsonst parken und so
sieht's jetzt hier aus
herzlich willkommen ich würde sagen
7:30 Uhr und dann gucken wir mal was ich
heute noch so erlebe
[Musik]
okay Leute da bin ich angekommen im
Zimmer ich muss sagen ich glaube so ein
großes Zimmer ich lange nicht ich wollte
noch was lustiges erzählen muss schauen
uns das einmal an ja mann Bett
ist aber schön Fernseher also hier ist
er wirklich enorm viel Platz also ich
glaube Hotels auf dem Land da hast du
immer da kannst du mit deiner ganzen
Großfamilie einziehen Badezimmer sieht
auch gut aus
und so ist der Blick nach draußen ja
wunderschön ich bin gerade auf jeden
Fall so reingegangen und unten an der
Rezeption ist schon Mädel die ist auch
noch so ein bisschen jünger und entweder
es ist heute ihr erster Tag hier oder
zweite Möglichkeit sie kennt mich von
Youtube bei mittlerweile kann ich das
ganz gut einschätzen wenn mich Leute so
kennen und die hat mir sowas immer
gezeigt und war so Turbo nervös ich
dachte so hey was geht ab bei dir und
dann also manchmal vergesse ich das auch
das so Leute vielleicht die Youtube
Videos gucken oder mich schon mal
gesehen haben oder mich vielleicht sogar
aktiv verfolgen wer weiß und ist ja auch
absolut random das ich einfach hier in
Rotenburg an der tollwie ist das nochmal
Rotenburg ob der Tauber dass ich einfach
hier so stumpf übernachten danach naja
auf jeden Fall schaue ich mir jetzt kurz
an was das hier eigentlich für eine
Stadt ist und dann gehen wir nach
draußen weil ich weiß nicht ich hoffe
ich bekomme noch irgendwas zu essen ich
habe nämlich übel machen also rotenburg
ob der Tauber gibt's da kein
Wikipedia-Eintrag Rothenburg ob der
Tauber ist eine mittelfränkische
Kleinstadt im Landkreis Ansbach in
Bayern mit der weitgehend erhaltenen
mittelalterlichen Altstadt ist die große
Kreis durch viele Einwohner haben die
eigentlich 11.000 Einwohner okay das ist
jetzt nicht so viel ne mit der waldkind
erhalten mütterlichen Altstadt ist die
große Kreisstadt Rotenburg eine
weltbekannte Sehenswürdigkeit mit vielen
Baudenkmälern und Kulturgütern ich habe
von dieser Stadt noch nie in meinem
Leben gehört also anscheinend ist das
echt sehr touristisch sogar auch hier
sonst wird wahrscheinlich diese 10-15
Hotels gar nicht geben weil 11000
Einwohner ist ja an sich nicht viel ja
super interessant also ich freue mich
ist eigentlich glaube ich ein geiles
Ziel auf jeden Fall interessanter als
dieses Kaff wo ich bei der letzten Folge
gelandet bin vor einem Jahr kurz einmal
Gesicht waschen und dann schauen wir uns
Rotenburg an okay Leute auf geht's in
die Stadt ich bin mal gespannt wir haben
auf jeden Fall schon mal die erste
Baustelle aber mal gucken was dahinter
kommt okay ich muss sagen damit hätte
ich jetzt hier echt nicht gerechnet aber
schaut mal also erster du bist auf jeden
Fall ganz nett sieht bisschen aus wobei
das die Häuser sind ja schon moderner so
ein bisschen zumindest ne wir denken uns
jetzt mal die Bagger hier weg aber wenn
man hier runter schaut sieht schon auf
jeden Fall sehr sehr mittelalterlich aus
und ich gehe mal davon aus dass es eine
Stadt die in erster Linie von Rentnern
besucht wird deswegen hier
wahrscheinlich gleich alles dicht ist
ich habe gerade mal geguckt Restaurants
maximal bis 22 Uhr auf schauen wir mal
okay bevor ich was Essen gehen muss ich
erstmal gucken wie es hier so aussieht
ich bin irgendwie zu neugierig so sieht
übrigens die Sprache Sparkasse aus sieht
aus wie eine Burg und wir sind auch
super viele ausländische Touristen ist
mir jetzt mal aufgefallen ey manchmal
obwohl ich schon mein Leben lang in
Deutschland wohne bin ich irgendwie
trotzdem man hört überrascht
ey was geht denn hier ab da vorne ist
Fußgängerzone so und hier kommen wir
jetzt glaube ich zum Marktplatz also
hier ist es jetzt ein bisschen belebter
es ist echt wie Mittelalter hier
wow hier suche ich mir auf jeden Fall
jetzt irgendwas zu essen Volksbank ah ja
hier wird Game of Thrones gedreht echt
sehr sehr schön also damit hätte ich
wirklich heute überhaupt nicht gerechnet
dass ich hier in unserem Ort Lande hier
scheint auf jeden Fall auch immer so ein
Weinfest oder so zu sein alles ist hier
voll mit so Weinständen nur das ist
vermutlich am Wochenende und wie gesagt
heute ist Dienstag Rotenburg ist geil
okay Leute ich habe jetzt gerade
erfahren dass man eigentlich um diese
Uhrzeit überall hier reservieren muss
weil das so ausgebucht ist und jetzt
habe ich aber freundlicherweise noch
einen Tisch bekommen kann aber sein dass
hier noch andere Gäste dazu kommen
gleich und jetzt passt mal auf ja
Game of Thrones
es geht hier ab
okay Leute aufgegessen ich habe jetzt
nicht weiter mit gefilmt da habe ich
noch zwei andere kennengelernt mit denen
habe ich mich ganz nett unterhalten die
wissen jetzt auch dass ich
YouTube-Videos mache also falls ihr seht
schöne Grüße und jetzt ja also ich
glaube hier ist jetzt tot Hose aber mal
schauen wir sehen können Leute es ist
auch schon dunkel wir haben jetzt 3
Minuten vor 10 Uhr also abends und die
letzten Läden hier machen um 22 Uhr zu
das heißt jetzt da ist alles dicht ich
habe gerade mal geschaut und es gibt
auch wirklich keine Bars oder so mehr
die auf haben weil die Bars und so
gesehen auch in diesem alten bayerischen
Restaurants drin ja ich muss gleich mal
schauen wenn ich im Hotel bin ob es denn
hier irgendwelche Sachen gibt außer sich
alte Häuser anzugucken was man halt so
machen kann und das machen wir dann
einfach morgen früh oder ob es irgendwas
gibt was ich jetzt noch machen kann weil
ich bin ja noch fit bin ja eigentlich
nicht hier hingefahren und um 22 Uhr
schlafen zu gehen aber Baustelle gibt's
auch ach so Leute ich habe euch gerade
auf Instagram gefragt wer denn aus roten
bekommen und was man noch so machen kann
und da meinten viele ja es gibt doch
diesen Kannibalen von Rotenburg aber das
ist nicht dieses Rotenburg also das
Rotenburg kann ich auch das wird aber
ohne TH geschrieben also nur mit einem
Tee das ist irgendwo in Hessen und das
hier ist aber Rothenburg an der Tauber
Taubsi ich hatte das jetzt schon ein
paar mal wenn ich so irgendwie
Reisevideos gedreht habe manchmal ist es
ein bisschen unbefriedigend wenn man
will noch irgendwas machen und irgendwas
zeigen aber es gibt einfach nichts oder
einem Feld halt nichts ein und hier ist
es jetzt irgendwie wieder genauso ich
habe keinen Plan was ich hier jetzt noch
machen soll vielleicht schreibt mir noch
irgendwas auf insta Instagram Alex wie
könnt ihr gerne rein folgen aber ich
step jetzt erstmal zum Hotel weil hier
ist wirklich gar nichts mehr hier ist
alles zu und ich bin noch mal gespannt
ob ich morgen noch irgendwas machen kann
außer Renten aber beim Frühstücken zu
Filmen ja ja gute Nacht und damit ein
wunderschönen guten Morgen aus
Rothenburg ob der teuer war ich muss
sagen ich habe echt sehr sehr gut
geschlafen und wir gehen jetzt
frühstücken ich habe gestern auf
Instagram noch jede Menge Nachrichten
bekommen ich muss unbedingt einen
Schneeball Essen keine Ahnung was es ist
wenn wir herausfinden und einmal zum
mittelalterlichen Museum das ist der
Plan für jetzt ich muss jetzt erstmal
Auschecken ja schauen wir mal die oben
hier mir hat gerade der anderen Omi und
trockenen Abend gewinnt ich hoffe das
war nicht auf Alkohol gezogen vielleicht
ist Sie hier den Wein verfallen oder
halt einfach dass es heute regnen soll
und ich glaube da vorne ist jetzt ein
Kaffee und da gibt's dann Schneeball
schauen wir mal super aus
[Applaus]
hallo haben sie hier in Schneeball ja
ich hätte gerne was ist denn der
klassische
mit Puderzucker ja dann nehme ich den
noch mal unten Cappuccino wäre super
danke schön
hauptsache ich komme noch nicht mal dumm
vor mit meiner Kamera er kommt einfach
mit ganzen Stativ
jetzt gibt's auf jeden Fall zu morgen
erstmal hier den Schneeball die
Bäckereifachverkäuferin war auch richtig
begeistert von mir ich das Gefühl
das sieht ja wirklich sehr interessant
aus sowas soll ganz besonders schmecken
2,50 € bisschen trocken bisschen Zucker
bei naja weiß ich jetzt nicht mehr dazu
sagen
schlechter Schneeball
also Leute ich muss leider sagen der
Schneeball hat mich gar nicht überzeugt
vielleicht war es ein schlechter
Schneeball keine Ahnung wir schauen uns
jetzt hier noch das mittelalterliche
Kriminalmuseum an da gibt's wohl
ziemlich viele Folterinstrumente die man
mal sehen sollte wie das im Mittelalter
also abging und ja finde ich persönlich
spannend für die Leute die keinen Bock
drauf haben ihr könnt ja dann
ausschalten weil ich glaube danach habe
ich auch alles gesehen hier und hier
vorne ist jetzt noch die Burg von
Rotenburg
also es gibt hier auf jeden Fall super
viele enge Gassen wo man ganz entspannt
spazieren gehen kann da vorne müsste
jetzt gleich noch das Kriminalmuseum
sein und ich glaube wenn man mal so eine
Weintour machen will und noch nie einen
Rotenburg ob der Tauber war fahrt ihr
mal hin ich glaube das kann echt bocken
gerade wenn man hallo ich glaube das
kann auf jeden Fall Spaß machen so da
haben wir es doch schon
mittelalterliches Kriminalmuseum
das sieht auf jeden Fall nach irgendwas
ist schon auf dem Marktplatz da wurde
irgendwer reingesteckt und dann wird
wahrscheinlich irgendwas mit dem gemacht
oder ey die Menschheit war damals so
grausam ne gut in gewissen Teilen sind
was sicherlich immer noch was haben wir
hier
verkehrsünder
Umweltverschmutzer was das gab schon
damals hängt
Kriminalmuseum ja wahrscheinlich oder
meinte das ist original das ist das noch
original also aus Mittelalter oder wird
das nachgebaut das hält sich ja nicht so
lange oder was ist das denn für ein
verstrahlter Wagen da wurden Kinder
reingesteckt ach so das ist aber nur aus
dem Film okay
vielleicht hätte ich lieber hier den
Schneeball kaufen sollen dass ich
irgendwie besser aus das hier vor mir
ist jetzt der Plön nennt sich das das
ist das Zentrum von Rotenburg also
dieses Haus da und irgendwo ist dann
drin ich fühle mich auch irgendwie im
Geschichtsunterricht was ich euch
erzähle also das ist soweit kommt ja
klasse sieht doch schön aus YouTube 25
gefangen im Körper 1 60 irgendein paar
Marktplätze an aber schönes Haus aber
ich bin noch zu jung dafür tut mir leid
aber was machen wir jetzt noch eine
weitere Sache die man in Rotenburg
machen kann und zwar es gibt ja diese
Burgmauern wie sie hier jetzt auch sehen
könnt man kann da hochgehen und dann
einmal so quer rumgehen also es geht
nicht ganz rum soweit ich weiß aber halt
schon ein Stückchen und ich wollte jetzt
auch einmal noch hoch gehen wenn ich
schon mal hier bin ich bin schon ganz
schön am schwitzen hier geht's nur auf
und ab
[Musik]
voll geil
Alter schaut mal ja also auf Sommer
heftigen burgmaul stand ich auch noch
nie und hier kannst du dann ein paar
Rentner raus beobachten moinsen früher
wurde dieses Loch natürlich benutzt um
die Burg zu verteidigen und hier gibt's
sogar eine Toilette schön man kann hier
auch optimal vortrinken wie man hier
sehen kann ey echt nice das auf die
Baustelle wieder und das geht halt
wirklich hier ganz außen rum schon echte
geile Sache jetzt habe ich mich
ausgesperrt
ja wie wäre es mit einer Nostalgie Tour
auf diesen Dingen so jetzt habe ich noch
einen Spot gefunden der mich richtig
interessiert und zwar ein geiler
Aussichtspunkt okay Leute das sieht doch
geil aus hier ist die alte Burgmauer
glaube ich von Rotenburg und da unten
kann man schön runter gucken also man
muss wirklich sagen Rotenburg ob der
Tauber ist der perfekte Drehort wie
irgendwelche mittelalterlichen Filme du
kannst hier so geile Kulissen erstellen
und man fühlt sich hier wirklich
teilweise wie Mittelalter ich glaube das
ist jetzt auch ein guter Spot hier das
Video zu beenden ich hoffe es hat euch
halbwegs gefallen auch wenn es sehr
historisch wurde beim nächsten Mal
machen wir das versprochen
europa-edition also dann irgendwo mit
Flugzeugen das wird denke ich ein
bisschen spannender zumindest für die
Jüngeren von euch ich weiß ja dass wir
auch mittlerweile etwas ältere Leute
meine Videos schon vielleicht findet ihr
es ja ganz gut mein geschichtsjahr von
damals würde das Video auf jeden Fall
hat feiern denke ich mal hast du noch da
abonniert den Kanal und ja
tschüss außer Rotenburg der teuer